[Music]
hi I'm Hannah your friendly neighborhood
wine mom tonight we're drinking Riesling
it's a great wine if you don't like wine
I don't know if you guys saw a couple
episodes ago we did a video about
texting and I gave out a phone number
for people to text me and I got so many
texts I read every single one and it was
just so exciting to see how many people
watch the show and what you guys want me
to talk about so let's talk about
tonight's topic sex after childbirth
okay so first let's talk about what
happens to your lady parts your hoo-ha
your baby maker your vajayjay so when
you first leave the hospital a lot of
people don't realize that your child
will go home in diapers and you will
also go home in diapers
and multiple paths and a little spray
bottle to clean it off because after
having a baby there's still a bunch of
gunk left in there and your body's gonna
be slowly expelling it over the next few
weeks and you literally need a freaking
diaper to contain everything for the
first few weeks when I would lay down
and then sit back up it felt like I
fully peed my pants with a full bladder
like it would just be like it was like
pink colored stuff I don't know what it
is it's something that's up in there but
like duh you just had a baby that's your
uterus is like Jesus has been doing this
for nine months just like let me refresh
myself on top of it I had to you vaginal
birth there's gonna be some trauma there
there's gonna be swelling and there's
gonna be pain you don't know if you're
gonna get stitches you never know what's
gonna happen I just remember trying to
get up out of the bed like okay I'm
gonna count one okay no no it's not
worth it I don't need any water with my
first son he was dying pounds
he was gigantic and as I was pushing him
out I remember the doctor was saying Oh
shoulders seven broad shoulders on this
cane and I was just like hopefully saw
my six-week checkup the doctor cleared
me to have sex and I was like are you
kidding me I didn't even look down there
I didn't even want to see what had
happened for a good nine months and then
finally after nine months I took a
mirror and
you know like Oh looks the same and then
with my second child he was a very small
child but we came a little bit early it
was much easier but still I don't know
if six weeks is enough time to recover
from that
so all words have different recovery
periods this is just mine so while I was
cleared at six weeks to physically have
sex that's not even delving into the
emotional part I have a huge emotional
factor when it comes to sex like I have
to feel emotionally ready and I have to
feel emotionally okay with it that's for
my first child I was not emotionally
money for over a year because I was just
so paranoid about getting pregnant again
I never wanted that to happen I was so
scared it's like when you have a really
bad hangover
and you're like oh god I'm never
drinking again this is it so I know what
your seems like a long time but for me
that was just what I needed to kind of
get my life together and a huge part on
top of the physical recovery is your
hormones during imbalance the [ __ ] out
there are all these like ups and downs
throughout pregnancy of your hormones
and then you give birth and then
everything's trying to level out I had
to watch Jersey Shore it was the only TV
show I could watch without crying
after I had my first son because I was
like this is the I I can't feel sorry
for anyone in this so with my second son
I was married and that brings a whole
other factor of another person who is
trying to love and support me while I'm
trying to heal but they also have their
needs so it certainly wasn't a year
before I had sex after my second but it
was a good three months I think I kind
of found that balance and everyone says
everything's easier with your second
which I guess that was let's talk about
doing the damn thing so when I finally
did have sex I had all these
misconceptions from what I'd heard from
other people about what it was gonna be
like it just it totally blew all those
out of the water like none of that
actually happened I had heard that
you're never gonna be wet again you
always need Lube never been a problem
for me I'd heard that because it had
been so
there was so much anticipation it was
gonna be amazing and it really was not
it was super awkward it was like losing
your virginity again it was just like
what do I do with my hand then the third
misconception I had was that your vagina
is never gonna be as small as it once
was
and I want to put this to rest once and
for all
I get asked this all the time and it's
such a stupid [ __ ] question your
vagina goes back to normal there is no
problem there it's a wonder muscle and
it goes right back don't ask me anymore
and I know a lot of pregnant people
watch this show so I hope that this
might have calmed your fears a little
bit because you can have as much sex as
you want or don't have sex at all that's
all I got for today I'm Hannah your
friendly neighborhood wine mom and if
you have a topic you want me to talk
about in a future episode leave it in
the comments or you can still text me
I'm digging my way through the messages
trying to reply to them but at the very
least I read them and I appreciate them
and I love interacting with you guys
till next time your vagina has been
stewing your vagina has been stretched
to capacities it didn't even know was
what was livable your vagina has been
stretched to capacities it didn't know
what was